transitioning from full-time distance
education that's the consideration for
clark county school district board of
trustees that's going to happen this
thursday
now not a lot of details are known about
what that may look like but
8 news now reporter kristen drummond
received some insight about the possible
plan
the district has not yet publicly posted
about a possible transition plan but
is trying to gather feedback and needs
parents to answer a questionnaire
tonight
we have two options giving families a
choice
i would really like for them to be back
in school at least even if it's just a
few days
paula guaman answers a ccsd survey with
four
questions it asks parents to decide
which educational option works best for
their students
going forward it was either online
learning for the rest of the year
or having the hybrid which is two days
in person and three days online
the other three questions deal with
transportation logistics
it's just something that's on the air
uncertainty as
ccsd develops a transition plan from
what i understand at this point
it would not be an entire day principal
tam larnard at spring valley high school
tells me
what parents can likely expect at the
high school level
from what i'm understanding is that
physically the students would be here in
the morning
and then the remainder of the day they
would be at home
attending school virtually in the
afternoon after after lunch
lernard says that allows the custodial
staff to clean the entire afternoon
get ready for the next students that
come the next day a safety consideration
as
families choose the best option for
their child kristin drummond 8 news now
and we can tell you just moments ago
ccsd announced that it's now going to
extend the survey deadline because they
do want to hear from more families
but they didn't say until when a date
has not been set for implementation of
that hybrid model if trustees
do indeed approve it on thursday